foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the break room Our Daily
Show like keeps you updated on all the
nerdy news you need to know uh we're
sorry we missed you guys yesterday our
internet went out and Tommy couldn't fix
it and he started it so I didn't start
the fire I just want to say Tommy and I
love you put you saying on Twitter that
the Wi-Fi was out as the problem I mean
it's like the internet is out the Wi-Fi
is a product of the internet oh yeah
he's like my mom explaining I have to
say you're absolutely right I also sent
our social media manager Tyler shout out
to him uh like the the notification that
we didn't have uh internet and I forget
and I was like basically I sent him all
the uh technologically incorrect things
he deciphered my incoherent message and
was like oh this is what you mean to say
right and I was like yes I don't know
what I'm talking about I'm sorry you did
great I think whenever anything goes
wrong electrically the Wi-Fi is out is
the reason one time my car exploded I
said Wi-Fi yeah I'm an idiot listen
people I'm not a smart person you
shouldn't listen to me I'm using the old
Joe Rogan you are the equivalent I'm
just not closing the door you're gonna
let out my lights
bill all over them grandmother was like
you know yeah exactly my grandma used to
say about my library if you flip the
switch
well yeah I never had a grandma coming
up we're back from the dead oh yeah baby
just one Grandma did you have another
one right no we only have one in my
family
for the asexual population of Jessica my
grandma might be Mary our black panther
two spoiler free review
I I had a video that came out today too
about it uh knives out to you guys the
acolyte cast announcements and Angelina
Jolie was supposed to be a Marvel what
playing in the Spider-Man movie
and somewhere here maybe there might be
a murder a murderer are we calling that
now well I don't know if I need to do I
would like to know who we're talking
about specifically oh yeah really
because I feel like I'm the guest in I
don't trust this [ __ ] at all let's
introduce who the possible murderers
could be Jay Washington
um
no cause I'm black all right exactly so
murderer number two possibility Jessica
Clemons
can't beat Tommy
he's too pure
Tommy looks like every Netflix
documentary okay
killing Tommy he was he was quiet mostly
kept to himself until the night he
didn't what came next was an evening of
Carnage we haven't seen since
well maybe ever 15 were dead by the time
he finished his Rampage oh with a simple
butter knife this
is breaking back told oh my God that's
breaking back it was sad that he's got
his whole intro down yeah I'm terrified
he can't be the Killer is and Brandon
Bechtel Brandon
soon I hope bad news for my wife I'm
moving on for me
sorry Mrs Barrick it's Bechtel dad and
for our Redemption change your monogram
oh thank you perfect and for our
Redemption today we have no official
Redemption but we will try and answer as
many of those super chats that you guys
send like Cory's Gucci to the moochie
welcome back yeah we're happy to be back
Corey Iceman are also sending in uh uh a
super jet saying choo choo NF yeah yeah
and uh we also just want to bring up
that uh it was a bummer that the NFL
canceled all their games last weekend
and there were no results Ah that's just
too bad so uh hopefully next week the
NFL will pick back up where it left off
and the first place Buffalo Bills it
sounds like he's blocking something out
oh
[Laughter]
Tommy's breaking out at hives uh well
this isn't a football podcast at least
not yet anyways uh but before we get
into our headline today we're gonna
switch things up a little bit uh and get
it to our discussion first you may have
noticed in the thumbnail we want to talk
a little bit about Black Panther what
kind of forever now we're in a bit of a
precarious situation I myself am the
only one on the panel who has not seen
the film yet uh these three wonderful
people have already seen the film uh I
don't like the way you said it because
when someone says these three wonderful
people have seen this film in other
words these three [ __ ] who've
seen movie I ain't seen [ __ ] yeah yeah
inside of me is a boiling pit of anger
that is about to erupt into a volcano uh
uh the weather is very hard here in
Manitoba where we are located so if you
hear any we have this stay here together
I'm eating you first oh yeah
um but how quick are we going into
eating people yeah I mean that was like
out the game like he's got a good eight
hours a lot of pop culture is based on
cannibalism right now we were talking
about it's in the Zeitgeist
um anyways Jessica already has a
spoiler-free review of black panther
wakanda forever up on the channel right
now so check that out after you watch
the break room today be sure to like And
subscribe if you haven't already uh but
since Jay Jessica and Tommy have already
seen the movie can we get like a one
sentence spoiler-free review from each
of you yes uh don't don't spoil anything
we might be flooding here
mad that we're doing this review does
anyone call him Neymar
just no more actually ever K Ross calls
him Neymar
ever ever Martin Freeman's uh voice
accent that he does sounds just like my
Uncle Jim he's got like kind of a
soft-spoken western New York accent and
it makes me feel honored it makes me
feel like I'm like my uncle I feel like
a lot of Brits use they go for a kind of
an accent somewhere New York I think is
a good accent for Brits doing an
American accent to use right it's got a
nice twing I love when they they like I
like a specific region like um Margot
Robbie is like I love Brooklyn she was
like I love Brooklyn it's my number is
that what already supposed to be
technically yes Toronto because it's not
New York right but it is okay all right
I thought she was supposed to be a
telekinesian oh maybe oh hey John should
I should my one sentence be the thing I
said to you earlier today
okay here's my did you get to do yours
no no no
so here's my thing about black pants
they were kind of forever non-spoilery
movie I think this movie Perfectly
executes what Kevin feige has seems to
be the direction he wants to move in and
that is taking the emphasis off of a
post-credits scene that everyone is just
waiting for the movie to be over with to
get to and instead saves the surprises
and the Gasping moments for in the film
there are multiple oh holy s moments in
this film that they happen within moving
the story forward rather than it just
being a race to get to the finish to see
what's next for the MCU it makes you
really appreciate and be in the movie
and be present more so don't go in there
just waiting to burn through to see
what's coming next right sit in it enjoy
the surprises bring your uh kids over an
appropriate age because it's I just
think it's a magical movie on par with
like the first Guardians movie and then
you know the movies of my youth Goonies
Star Wars those Etc so far that's all I
gotta say beautiful yes Jessica uh that
was more than one sentence
you guys are being paid I um I mentioned
this in my review but I for a very
ambitious movie because there's so much
going on I think they packaged it very
nicely especially with all of the stuff
prior to what they had to deal with from
like them having to go on hiatus because
of kovid
um our boy dying everything happening
they really package something so nicely
with so much in it there's so much to
take away yeah yes go watch Jessica's
incredible review of the film uh it's
really free right yeah spoiler free
review embargo lifted today so we put it
out there enjoy it it's a great I think
it's a good primer before you go see the
movie especially if you're uh you know
it's I mean it's been a minute since the
first black panther came out give
yourself a little dust up watch the
review have you watch it of course I did
I watched all of you let's say dust up
when referring to the MCU it's
triggering oh God give us a sentence
it's just a blip on your screen oh
you don't see it in a snap
anymore no that's it okay no more got
any no more Nate more let me say you
know think about it
I uh I said it on Twitter I'll tighten
it up
he's taking the glove off
hey okay only I have the stones to keep
talking about this I could go on for
Infinity
okay the second part was better
um I said this on Twitter it hits every
note you wanted to hit they get everyone
knows this they get the most hardest
part out the way early okay the best
thing is you know the funeral happens we
all seen it in the trailers we know the
death happens they get it out the way
early and then when I say early it's
before the cold open before the even
Marvel crawl because it's basically that
and it's not a spoiler it's basically
that you know what's happening yeah
let's get this out the way so this way
the the the impending death isn't
looming over the front you know it's
about the memorial and memorializing him
throughout the movie but Neymar Namor is
a beast um I believe they call him
every part you hear in the trailer in
the movie hits 40 times when you see
where it is oh my God especially when
you find out whether Angela bassett's
speech is oh Lord stop I didn't say
where it was it's in the movie it's in
the it's in the trailer we heard it in
the trailer so soon guys we are 72 hours
away from everyone being on the same
page and I can't wait I got a lot to say
gonna say there are a few people in the
chat making me borderline uncomfortable
about the personal details of my life no
I'm just kidding uh there are some
people just uh asking for me to get into
precarious situations what yeah Tommy
Bechtel I have a tattoo of you across my
chip
and beg for you to be my friend four
days a week can be because we can base a
ROM crime on it beautiful stuff yeah
that's nice I don't know what okay I
hate to say I want to know this tattoo
you on somebody's chest looks like I
hope it looks like this
shouldn't even open my door uh by the
way I'm starting to look like gritty the
Philadelphia
I have a great news I'm going to uh but
Barbara on Friday so we're gonna clean
this thank goodness go to Barbizon I
love it don't get rid of it uh anything
else you want to add on that jam uh yeah
besides that the movie does what it
continued to do it's explorable conducts
explored outside of a wakanda but also
it goes to what Tommy says Kevin feige
keep is consistently showing you the
Marvel universe is expansive it's not
just about characters anymore it's about
the World At Large and that's what this
movie does and of course it doesn't go
to the whole yo what's the post credit
scene was the main credit scene it's
just like enjoy them you enjoy the movie
because you'll literally be like I don't
know when I can go pee if I gotta pee so
I'm gonna do this beforehand so it's a
great one well that's good to hear
because I do feel like phase four has
been very interesting in that like we've
had several movies with new characters
like shangshi and like the eternals
where it's very refreshing to be like oh
these are characters everything in this
movie's new it's not connected to the
stuff uh you know I'm I'm learning I'm
I'm everything in this movie is new and
I enjoy it we've also had the movies
that are several uh films deep in a
franchise right no way home is our third
Spider-Man in the MCU plus two other
Spider-Man plus three other Spider-Man
right uh and then uh you're already in
store yeah yeah Thor was uh the fourth
in a franchise uh Doctor Strange was the
sequel but also like a sequel of One
Division so I I am excited for for a
movie that is a continuation of like a
franchise but still feels fresh and yeah
I do feel that fatigue too of like oh I
just wanna we gotta get to the end
credits we get to the next thing I mean
I I feel like a story that never ends as
a person who has been guilty of this I
say there's only as someone who is
probably the most guilty after all these
Disney Plus shows give me a post-credit
scene right give me a teaser for next
week and half the time you're like
why like just watch the show and then
like get to like you know enjoy live in
the moment be present but it's kind of
like that first gift the first Black
Panther movie was one of the things I
said it was its own self-contained movie
It wasn't until the post-credits scene
in the first Black Panther movie was it
really convincing anyone else
except that break hey Ross but I mean
but you really don't count because you
don't even really think about that you
know it's just okay he was in Civil War
for a second yeah where this is kind of
the same thing it's really its own
self-contained movie yeah all the events
and everything have happened but this
movie stands on itself and what it does
is it like I said it spans the Marvel
Universe okay uh well as an avatar for
the audience being the only one here who
hasn't seen this movie as my hatred
inside grows stronger every day uh thank
you thank you uh I thought it might be
fun to kind of talk about uh an aspect
of the story that we don't know very
much about and that seems to be a big
departure from what the comics have
given us thus far uh that would be the
people of talocon AKA a the Tallow Canal
which uh we looked Kevin feige said that
in an interview on the red car I still
don't believe it I don't care I thought
he called him the telekinesians no we
that was a specious rumor that our
advice was speaking
I found an interview where he said Tello
Camille yeah and it was like you could
have put that out yesterday my guy let
us know what these things are called
he doesn't know what he's talking about
it's his world we're just living in it
folks um so let's start
what we know about Atlantis is very
confusing from the comic books uh uh and
what director Ryan coogler he put some
inspiration from that and also from real
life right it was his kind of idea to
give like a culture to what we knew as
the atlanteans but now of the Tallow
Canal right based on like an actual
culture right there is a talocon within
uh uh Mayan culture Mayan culture right
there is a cuckoo con who's also very
similar to quetzalo yes right National
they're like the different names for the
same kind of God a serpent God right
um but the comics so you have Atlantis
in the comics it's an old city it's
above uh it's above the water line next
to lemuria there's the great cataclysm
which sinks the city the P some people
live some people die it's very confusing
in the comics it's been retried a few
times right uh and at some point ten
thousand years ago homo mermainus
appears and those are Homo mermanas uh
and these would be the atlanteans right
and there's a lot of debate about where
they even came from some Say the
original because this is so crazy before
before Atlanta sank right some people in
Atlantis had a vision that this was
going to happen so they built a dome
ahead of time they're like trust us guys
You're Gonna Want a dome in this
neighborhood and it was like a dome and
they don't even explained what it was
made of it was like a plastic like
substance I don't know how it worked
because some people like survive the
sinking and they're underwater but
they're still humans and they're like
well what do we do now we're just uh we
just live in the dome yeah so there's
different theories one is that the
atlanteans are actually aliens from the
planet vodan who like came could already
live underwater they found a city
underwater that everyone was dead in and
they're like well we'll take this oh
there's a little Squadron rights right
now right right exactly another theory
is that the humans that lived down there
they were changed either through
Evolution or through magic uh into water
breathing home over Manus where because
both the
the lemurians who were next to Atlantis
they were part of the deviants remember
the deviants folks I remember the
deviants the deviants in the internal
the deviants in the eternals had some
underwater breathing abilities because
in the comics the eternals are not
robots they're like created I don't
there's one thing I didn't like about
the eternal life okay one thing one of
these things yeah because the deviants
there are no look there's no specific
look to it right here and yeah they all
just they just go underground because
they're just hideous so they I reread
the uh the dream of celestial Saga and a
couple other ones before internals came
out and I remember that like the
deviants they just was looking like
there's one there's one deviant he looks
like a pretty dude and they're like no
you're a deviant he's like but I look
normal and like get your ass on the
ground that's literally what they do to
like the monsters where he's the one
pretty long he's the Maryland monster of
the deviance and they put them
underground and so the thing what they
did in the movie with how all of them
had this weird look except for Crow
which had don't know how he got a name
all of a sudden I digress so continue
yeah yeah so so yeah there there's a lot
of debate in the comics of where the you
know atlanteans even came from what they
were are they aliens or the humans that
evolved but they basically have become
Homer Romanus and then Neymar in the
comics right he is the product of a homo
sapien father and a homer Madness mother
they combine boom you got Neymar right
it's a little bit about it
I don't know how babies are born but
that's what I've been told uh that's so
funny I can't believe you predict that's
exactly how it happens well what do you
know I saw I saw the scenar chair where
they're underwater having the baby and
you see a little air bubble come out
yeah
uh as a father of two I don't remember
seeing anything I don't believe you're
part of the big birth conspiracy theory
yeah
it's not wrong
in the film like Ryan coogler very I
think I definitely was like let's give
you know let's not call it Atlantis
because they they were planning to do
this story before Aquaman and all that
came out right and so they're probably
like let's not call it Atlantis let's
not call them atlanteans and let's give
them a little more like culture right so
he kind of lays on this like Aztec
telecon real world culture about a rain
God and like telecon in Aztec culture
was like part of the after World it was
where people who drowned or were struck
by lightning uh that's where they that
was their afterlife they went there
because there were several Realms of the
afterlife uh I'm I'm very much giving
you a condensed version of Aztec uh
mythology but that was part of it right
yeah uh so what do we know about these
Tallow Canal from the trailer right okay
and you guys do not spoil anything okay
when you were going through them I was
like do you want to know
I was looking safely like we're all like
yo we can tell you I don't want to spoil
anything but I do want to give a shout
out to the yucatani Aztec uh and Mayan
uh
um uh which uh ancestor Uh current day
descendants is what I mean they've
rehabilitated the Jaguar population in
that region in real life as of today no
longer an endangered species in the
Yucatan Peninsula that's great well done
and I think that should have been our
discussion may have had something to do
oh okay the dollar Canal may have helped
the Jaguars Tommy you saying that means
one thing to me what's up looks like
Jaguars back on the menu boys
throw them out throw them out in the
rain
get rid of it I can't believe he's gonna
be fine of course this is your husband
as a Floridian that's what happened in
Florida Gators were on the endangered
species list we got him back and now
they're like there's too many Gators
starting yeah Gator bites in every
restaurant I'd rather get oh
what if I do I want me a good Jaguar
Burger media I'll tell you what now I
think you know I think there was it uh
there's a lot of jungle cat symmetry in
the film and I hope in in the future uh
Taylor Canal uh uh imagery we get some
Jaguars out get some Jaguars I think the
thing is though with the movie with what
they did with the talocon there they
took Aztec and Mayan they Blended up
both of them and it was beautiful what
they did in the respect and reverence
especially if you look at namora's
jewelry and everything he's decked in
yeah it literally is all paying
reverence it is in the like the um
what's the light like the turquoise yeah
there's so much within it but you find
out so much more about everything he's
wearing and okay there's a reason for
everything you asked for him
for it I didn't spoiled here's John John
Z and I we went through the data okay we
comb through the trailers we come
through the uh all the little
featurettes there's too many don't watch
them all because there's a lot of
information out there but here's some of
the things I've pieced together okay the
Tallow Canal they live underwater that's
right but but if you look at the trailer
they're blue when they're out of the
water but underwater they're still what
I would call flesh colors yes okay I
interviewed her uh which is very oh
she's oh she amazing okay
six and a half minutes she can hold her
breath underwater for six and a half
minutes David Blaine you better watch
your back I know
six and a half minutes in our interview
and she was very like how did you about
it did you give her like a math test is
her brain about that I said girl you're
a fish and she said yeah yeah I saw a
video one time where a girl held her
breath for like five minutes under water
it was a Jacuzzi
that was on a different website I think
it was one of those Studios what is it
uh we're having a seriously
okay sorry woman drown on brown
eyes she was gagging for air
here's the craziest thing I've tried to
piece together okay they have some form
of technology in talocon because they
come out of the water and they have
these things on their faces and they're
able to breathe above water it looks
like now I I really wish it was like a
cartoon where they grab jellyfish and
they stick them on their face but it's
probably not bad so they have some sort
of technology I don't know how they
explain the pressure differential I
don't know how deep telecon is but I
would assume the pressure underwater is
stronger than that above land and if
they've learned the movie they've
learned somehow
yeah how can they come out I don't
remember their bones are stronger oh
their bones are stronger that's a new
Theory we'll say that for a big question
you want me to tell you no do not tell
me do not tell them why do atlanteans
have or tell accounts have such dense
bones so listen so for the first time we
get adamantium right it's officially
introduced okay it's on the shore of the
Yucatan Peninsula
and so that plays a big role okay okay
okay yeah I don't think he's done okay
maybe I don't know I can't trust anybody
uh okay so we have we have filthy mouth
what we've seen another Chiller so far
we've seen some desperate Fighters we
have no more who's who I'm assuming is
half Homo Sapien half tallo Canal maybe
he could be oh I don't know I don't know
because he doesn't appear to turn blue
when it comes out which makes me think
he's got a little homosapiens
you're supposed to be supporting them
what I can't tell from the trailer
footage is he's born under the water
very close to the Shoreline because
they're very you can see the top of the
water and it looks like the mother is
potentially Tallow Canal much like the
story would be in the comics it doesn't
look that's the father though I don't
know it looks like uh you see his daddy
ran out on him yeah I don't know his dad
there is that like also like dunking
down there for 30 seconds
you know I mean we were all tub births
right we were all giving birth to and a
five foot bathtub right five feet yeah
saying that like his mother told stories
about a place like wakanda so presumably
their people the the people of talocon
are not completely isolated but one
thing that's completely different in
this movie than the comics is there were
comments have no idea about talocarming
it's something that in the comics they
know about each other there's long
history they got diplomats in each
other's countries which that's got
that's a shitty dip with my job you
could have France you could have the
bottom of the [ __ ] ocean
oh we take France I take the bottom of
the ocean down there uh I know what's
down there a lot of water that could
[ __ ] kill me
I would send other people down there
across me what do you do for like
ashiness if you're in talocon when it's
like Houston like underwater don't you
think the humidity would be like strong
is there such a thing as
always
crunchy listening they're in the water
the jellyfish for the face they got the
jellyfish for the body there's different
jellyfish jellyfishes jellyfish
technology and let me tell you what's
wrong about it okay uh because I've seen
the movie
don't spoil anything
um we already talked about like Ryan
coogler is able to give them like uh
more specificity and like a kind of a
culture which I really like and I hope
we find out more of post movie here's
another thing I'm I'm gonna say and you
guys know the answer to this maybe
Tommy's having such a hard time not
telling you I know one thing we have to
think about right is if the more
assuming he survives this movie and I
would think he would he's a big
character I don't see a good reason to
kill him or if they do kill him they'll
bring in a multiversal variant at some
point I don't think no more he's not
he's not a one and done okay he got his
nipples out of the movie he's staying
around yeah he's got a lot of nipple
action sometimes you gotta have nothing
I think I think that's true because a
lot of people with their nipples
they killed that girl in Lethal Weapon 2
right after she okay that was a whole
different job she showed her nipples and
she ended up in the lake ironically
underwater
oh my gosh uh but is the more gonna be
like a friend or if uh going forward for
whatever the Avengers become or a friend
of me or a friend of me I mean in the
comics I would call him a friend of mine
I would just say that's what he is no no
matter what he's a friend of me no
matter what in front of me of the state
and that would make sense to like
continue on because he's still he's the
he's the leader of his people right so
no matter what his people come first you
know what I'm saying everybody else look
you need me for this Threat all right
I'm here only because my peoples I'm
listening to Jay oh I didn't know what
was no no keep going I'm listening okay
you listening so he's only there to help
because he's just people you know what
I'm saying anything right and so he's
like you know they can't hear you I'm
sorry I'm just trying to be here but no
so like they more and more is more so
about I'm protecting my people yeah so
any other threats where I team up with
y'all it's not because I really want to
help y'all right it's because it'll
affect my people in the long run yeah
and that's my that's my big theory for
the movie having not seen it is that
like uh
whatever pops off between telecon and
wakanda is a result of not the heads but
like the side characters causing
problems and then do you not the leader
in the trailer when the Neymar walks up
on Queen Ramona to look like look
if his associates started War he's got
to back his people right then all bats
are off I don't know that's what I'll
say this is the last thing I want to say
before because I want to be very careful
about spoilers two weirdest moments of
product placement for me was when uh
Neymar said oh we eat down here are
fudgicles uh I thought that was super
weird they don't even fudge with the
whale no they eat fudgicles fudgsicles
and then the other weird part was when
wakanda was just full of Dave and
Buster's ah there was just literally
like this is the Golden City Dave and
Buster's in wakanda and then they were
like what did they say What's the
difference between Starbucks
pigs in a blanket forever is what they
kept saying because they got those
little mini hot dogs ah all right
uh well shout out I can't I heard I
heard that name or only comes to the
surface so you can finally have a Coke
Zero that's true Coke and a smile and a
little tooth uh all right
we want to shout out the second season
of the hit show uh but DC's Batman the
audio Adventures which is out now on HBO
Max it's got an incredible cast Rosario
Dawson is the Catwoman John Leguizamo
Bobby Moynihan fan of the show friend of
the show fan of the show friend of my
heart Jeffrey Wright who played Jim
Gordon in the Batman is voicing the cave
Crusader himself in the show and let me
tell you I listened to a few episodes he
does great the guy has one of the best
voices working in the biz today uh last
night I listened to two episodes uh and
I am hooked guys I'm I'm gonna finish it
uh yeah I'm like a fish on a telokian
line I'm getting
uh why is there a Monroe Muffler breaks
down in the telecon all right there's a
story line with fun vignettes and
sketches full of Batman where there's so
many Easter eggs from all the DC Comics
if you listen this is a dream come true
from people four people at the center of
the SNL comic book fan Venn diagram if
you love SNL if you love comic books
write meet it right in the middle it's
incredible Swain The Joker musical guest
condiment man and your host
the doll maker okay it makes sense
because this show was created by a long
time SNL writer Dennis mcnicholas every
episode is written and directed by old
Denny and he stacked the cast with some
of the people we've mentioned before and
also Keenan Thompson Chris Parnell Seth
Meyers plays this amazing like uh radio
DJ who's just like kind of that's kind
of funny I mean it's funny but it's
funny in a dark way I will say like
don't go into being like I don't want
people to think I'm a real sicko more
than they already do but listen to the
first episode dives into some dark stuff
but it's done with a humorous tone it's
very like SNL dark humor uh some of the
sketches that worked the best on SNL I
think like Debbie Downer things like
that they skew towards darkness and
sadness and then make and find something
funny in it uh anyway yeah the Seth
Meyers was a standout for me kind of
plays the voice of the audience and like
this is insane why does Gotham City have
a food festival there's literally 19
super villains running around and again
so tune in for a tale of life and death
in Gotham City the whole first season is
already available in the Stream season
two is out now on HBO Max I cannot
recommend it highly enough listen along
with me maybe we'll chat about it on
Instagram live okay stream DC's Batman
the audio Adventure season two now on
HBO Max let's get to the headlines
please
it's about time so Ryan coogler
confirmed whose phone is that that
wasn't me it wasn't me I don't have an
iPhone because I'm not a sucker thank
you boom all right was that the game it
was me
it was me it was me it was me Jessica
Jessica either way Ryan coogler confirms
is a strong it wasn't something no it's
as strong as Thorin is as strong as Thor
and the hulky this is insane that man
with the tiny wings is just as strong as
the Hulk and Thor so literally in Thor
Ragnarok did you he could you could beat
him both he could beat them both
possibly so he says no equal in terms of
his capabilities being able to breathe
underwater and break uh and breathe at
high altitudes and walk around on land
he's incredibly strong he's the
strongest Thor and if he's around enough
water he can be as strong as the Hulk
keep that in mind uh he also addresses
Daniel kalua's character's absence he
says uh he's basically banished but
still in wakanda's borders because
it was probably because he decided with
killmonger in the first movie so they're
like no we remember that's why I didn't
understand people can be like where's
wakabi where's him he's a [ __ ]
traitor
yeah yeah he's the only one that didn't
have to do it like the the door milage
or that's their job is the back whoever
is in there what if uh what if he's just
hanging out with Zemo that would be
great I don't think he would that's the
thing is like I still think he's like
still for wakanda now I guess right now
sure he's like my girlfriend beat it
into me she stopped my freaking Rhino
from attacking a bunch of people she
probably gave him some tuned in threw
him in jail yeah yeah that's the perfect
this is what you are leaving behind
[Laughter]
I like that that's like that okay I
gotta call my travel agent I gotta go to
wakanda soon it's real right God is real
yeah that's not the only spiritually
I'm going to show you something okay
okay oh my God don't freeze I never
freeze I didn't do an accident
um
and uh it's 4 36 so I can say this and
what the [ __ ] news oh Eric Andre has
been confirmed to appear in at least one
episode of Agatha coven of chaos and
also SNL Alum sashir zamada has also
joined the cast comedy cavalcade
MCU can I please literally
look I want to be a character that can
go from at least 150 Plus show to the
next movie I've got a reel come on
Jay has more reason to be on than I and
I stand can I have Eric Andre's maternal
no no
no no next headline Knives Out twos is
that how it works honey knives out two
this new trailer just dropped you guys
can go check it out because go check it
out
or tweet at John John loves it uh the
Star Wars acolyte gets a new cast
announcement and synopsis so now it says
the acolyte is a mystery thriller that
will take viewers into a galaxy of
shadowy Secrets and emerging Dark Side
powers in the final days of the high
Republic era a former Padawan reunites
with her Jedi Master to investigate a
series of crimes but the forces they
confront are Sinister than they are than
they ever anticipated is that Amanda
Amanda's gonna be the yeah is and then
Lee is going to be the why are you oh
that's written there no no that just
says here okay I can list off
no it's okay I deserve this no no no no
I deserve it okay
let's go through the entire cast right
now we got Amanda Sternberg and I'm not
gonna get into it because you should
know who she is she's amazing
she'll go after you first off the thing
is that lady shouldn't have been I agree
okay can we get to the castle okay from
squid game uh Manny Jacinto from nine
perfect strangers Daphne Keane that's
what we know
was anyone the good place yeah he wasn't
he was in Top Gun I think he's his agent
I think made it that it's not perfect
he's promoting I'm perfect
Daphne King from Logan Jody Turner Smith
from Queen and slim you can do other
movies like uh what's that what was that
movie she did with uh Michael B Jordan
how many times you guys gonna come for
the alternate uh
I'm sorry I'm sorry where are you
talking about Jody Turner Smith yes but
people know her for Queen and slim who
watched Queen of slim that wasn't
disappointed with Queen but they watched
it that's the thing they don't want to
remember that movie too bad
Rebecca Henderson from invented wasn't
cheating I'm just kidding
Charlie Barnett from Russian doll Dean
Charles Chapman from 1917. if you
remember that war movie that was pretty
good I like that movie I love that movie
oh my God we're so close so good Carrie
Anne Moss
we were so close
what about Jessica Jones other Star Wars
news according to deadline Sean Levy is
eyeing a galaxy far far away after he
finishes up Deadpool 3 for Marvel yeah
so am I what a Sean Levy got that I
don't got besides a huge career millions
of dollars probably billions of dollars
to anything he wants to do millions of
dollars I mean Star Wars is handing out
films we were talking about her on the
office like after being like oh we're
gonna pivot away from films for a little
bit yeah when they were trying two a
year and it didn't go so great uh and
then TV's been successful but now
they're like who wants a movie get back
to get people soon I got a girl that can
be in a Jacuzzi for five minutes
you need to soak once in a while space
can make you dehydrated
what is it and Star Wars uh oh she could
be in the back the tank okay send me her
own
yeah
folks you guys are setting it a lot
the back to tank is a sacred place
I'm gonna clapping them cheeks Spiderman
across the spider verse adds Daniel
Kalua as Spider Punk blue will voice the
character
um oh oh yeah I know him as hobby hobby
Brown AKA spider Punk the character is a
more recent Marvel Comics creation
having first appeared in the 2015 uh
right
the 2015 issues from Dan slot
we gotta hit a real life
dance lot uh Brown is are you
embarrassed of me Brown uh Brown is a
homeless teenager who becomes a hero to
be uh to the oppressed citizens of New
York in the dimensional Universe he uh
amazing thing I'll be doing a breakdown
on this character and the spider-verse
characters shortly yes
um Sony wanted Angelina Jolie to play a
major role in Spider-Man 4 Tobey
Maguire's Sequel and Sean O'Connell's
new book he reveals pieces to Sam Raimi
Spider-Man 4 if there was like vulture
being the ultimate uh villain and
Angelina Jolie coming on as well Jolie
would have played an accomplished yeah
go back to the photo again that had to
be Jolie because of that ass right
they did they did add like a diaper that
was that was like thickness right that
was no that wasn't a regular dude
wasn't that heavily Remembered at the
time
they want it
Jolie would have played an accomplished
executive representing a venture capital
firm that was trying to buy The Daily
Bugle the movie would have also been
opening with a montage of Spider-Man
taking down a bunch of different
villains like the Shocker stilt man
Mysterio and others
don't you think the way they describe it
do you think she would have been like
black cat oh I don't know oh my God this
would have been like uh
Tomb Raider
no Angelina Jolie is Felicia Hardy I
think that's maybe what they were doing
enough just on the prompter
[Music]
a non-comic character uh daughter of
that's why that ass was like that
I mean you got to go with James Fury
whenever great outline John sorry you
weren't respected enough to uh to have
that make the final prompter but one
company we do respect way more than John
is butcherbox we want to thank them for
sponsoring the break room today have you
started planning your Thanksgiving meal
no way
no I don't have family guess what start
with turkey and then surround it you're
fine are you looking to impress your
in-laws or your friends with a great
dish oh yeah I make my own cheesecake
don't settle for being the person who
brings the disposable plates and the
store-bought pie give yourself a free
range turkey from our friends at butcher
box you've heard us talk about butcher
box before don't at me how they take the
guesswork out of getting the highest
Quality Meats and Seafood by shipping a
variety of boxes straight to your door
they also throw in a recipe guide and
hex to make sure your cooking will blow
the socks off your uncle Gary and his
weird muscle so weird
I used to be somebody until they took
everything from me I don't like the woke
and I hope
well we here at the break room says
forget that guy we are big fans of the
grass-fed stakes and their wild caught
Seafood their scallops packed a wow oh
the main course for Thanksgiving dinner
can sometimes be a main source of stress
not anymore butcher box is offering our
listeners free turkey with their first
order sign up today at butcherbox.com
break room and use code break room to
get one 10 to 14 pound turkey free in
your first box that's butcherbox.com
break room use code break room to claim
this gobble gobble a good deal trash
bags sending a Super Chat asking does
butcher box have anything vegan yeah the
Box
[Laughter]
No Cap we do have a lot of great super
chats and a lot of great questions in
there we're going to get to those uh at
the end of the show so don't think we
don't see them we do see it's a great
Super Chat that poor person the Super
Chat hey thanks for your dollars you're
simp hey should I should I order a
butcher box if I live by myself in the
studio just so I can get one big ass
turkey and just like I think that's fair
Jay do you have if you're coming
research space for all the meat I think
you should order it Jay if you're in L.A
you can come to Thanksgiving with me
okay that's an invite I don't invited
you and he told me I can't come adorable
Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving is a time to come together
one time had a literal prostitute in my
house not on purpose she wasn't there
for me someone brought her as a plus one
and then her daughter showed up
stepdaughter I think they might have
been a teen anyway mandatory fun I
didn't have any fun that night no pay to
play you know what I'm saying
Hey Hey Thomas she was there for a hot
meal Thomas and then we gave her dinner
too he was trying to give it a mashed
potatoes
mandatory fund the only segment where we
don't pay for it so we played the
graphics because I adore it hit it again
I just said she could come and then also
show up at my house yeah tell me give it
up what about the stuffing did she get
the stuff
you're a side dish as well no put the
hand out
she did the same thing all right now
nice job to drop the trailer on us and
we decided would it be fun to live react
to the trailer you guys feel good about
that yeah I think so okay let's let's
start it up
all right there's a really expensive hey
there's a black dude
wait why are the lights out hold on I
kind of like is it the Rings is the
lights out is that one okay John did we
lose power John oh God is John okay John
looks dead John is he sleeping by his
tongue out that he's dead wait a second
is John dead John's been murdered what
I'm gonna go investigate I said it I I'm
a medium is that what I am if I knew
someone was going to die today if you
killed them did you kill them I look
like you was Bree okay thank God some
ghosts there's a note on his back does
it say kick me there's a note on his
back oh my gosh what did it say
John has died twice on this show wait
what what wait people died twice on the
show look here we should have told you
this when you first came out now ladies
and gentlemen my name is t Michael
beckwa Benoit no I'm too attracted to
this and obviously oh
oh you look like you can use the phrase
colored when they do your love oh my God
I'm here when I do my laundry is that
what you said yes
that's it now
and never any other time I vote blue no
matter who Auntie Michael back
okay now oh my God I'm so into it there
was a spooky poem on the back of the
deceased a clue
from the highest highs to the lowest
lows the truth is what my killer knows
oh three is all that took to drive him
mad an allen wrench to the plans he had
oh now it's very clear to me I'll murder
her today
was none other than Mr Brandon Barrett
back told Brandon who had the motivation
do it again who had the jealousy
what the [ __ ]
go if it's over
colvin's dead it wasn't me I was sitting
here the whole time Dr fauci murdered
cover In Cold Blood now Brandon yes sir
you killed John because you wanted more
power in the break room no I say it's
not true I mean I want more power but I
would never kill Jonah I can't I can't
go to jail look at me I'm not too
innocence
he's right he couldn't have killed John
John was killed during the blackout yes
someone to my right I would have noticed
I had my hand on your thigh the whole
time he had he was caressing my thigh
like a curious little spider the Itsy
Bitsy Spider ran up the juicy fat down
came the sun slowly massaging little
fast up came the fingers into the whole
bone all right a popular Ben wife you
know what I mean no I know who did it
Jay
must have been you Jay Washington you've
been dying to be on the show more yeah
and the only one who could book you for
all five days is Mr John Costa
I have a career outside of here
I'm Korea he's right I think he's also
just trying to make it sound like he
didn't do it I wonder if John books and
why would he kill John I'm on TV yeah
okay American Gigolo show time right now
all right now you actually have a real
career in the entertainment industry I
did forget about that which means to my
real murderer today the only person who
could have possibly killed John Z
Jessica Clemens
okay first off it was you Jessica I
would never kill John you wanted to kill
John because he pumpkin splashed out hot
dogs no you didn't know he had a three
hot dog lunch the next day
we all wanted the hot dogs I don't want
to be this person I don't want to be
this person but maybe it is Tommy
because uh excuse me very upset about
the bills and the Jets and this clearly
says my killer knows three is all it
took to drive him Matt didn't they lose
by three I don't know I don't watch
football it was like 17 to 20. you never
saw me
I think we consider all the NFL
problematic uh taishan Bankston sending
it to Super Chat thank you so much Alice
uh 2746 for our off-screen producer John
uh what we'll add it to his uh funeral
fund thanks so much uh uh star Walker
sending a Super Chat Jesus Christ this
rain got you all they did get us all
here in Manitoba it's a lot of rain out
uh Rupert Jamison sending in a Super
Chat listen I said it before New York
Jets All Season okay all right you know
what congratulations honestly uh Corey
can drill also invoking the name of the
Jets I think they're trying to anger you
no I understand listen I'm over it as
long as hopefully Josh Allen will be
okay that's all I want for my birthday
in two days
in charge of my finances
I'm in a conservatorship through I was
like wait what I like those actor has or
no your accountant he's your husband
yeah my husband can't be trusted with my
money he loves the shop shop till he
drop drops proud proud anyone Mama sings
Gino Smith MVP go Hawks I don't get it
oh God mama said that she said a lot of
problematic things she said Josh Allen
had no touchdowns he had two on the
ground okay total touchdowns too
I'd like to say shout out to Justin
Fields thank you for doing what you did
we know we lost but damage and look good
let me take you down again again I'd
like to just point out the entire entity
of the NFL is problematic uh course and
really sending a Super Chat do you think
people in Telecom dusted and what the
hell did they think happened this is my
favorite question for anyone outside of
the 28 members of The Avengers uh or
anyone living on Earth right any other
planet
suddenly everyone disappeared and then
five years later everyone came back this
must have happened in Telecom well they
just turn into clumps because it's like
you ever see what happened to the coffee
grinds after you do it that's what
everybody in telecon because it was
underwater they Dustin just like suggest
to them they just made one big telecon
telecon statue out of all the clothes
did it make bubbles
came back because they was all like Earl
I didn't know you felt like this also
what happened to the babies that were
dusted where they're just loose babies
everywhere
like if you were in an airplane and you
just did do you come back
the Russo Brothers
or like what if you what if you were
getting stabbed and then you dusted and
you come back but you still have to stab
the baby in your arms the Russo Brothers
Marcus simply said that like in his head
Hulk was like bring everyone back but
put them somewhere safe oh yeah you know
also I mean maybe if the location was
the same like if they're in an airplane
they just are in that airplane whether
it's yeah I did think about that I was
like Elena's so lucky she came back at
her friend's house still they had to put
a wall there
all right
oh [ __ ] Junior
ah
I caught the baby
until this is safely as you can but
Christian unpronounceable asking is the
snapping referenced in wakanda forever I
think Marvel's done referencing the blip
the snap no snapping move never calling
it The Blue
I think that it's always implied in all
of these right they reference it really
directly anymore because it's impossible
to be everything would be about that
they're constantly talking I mean it's
like you know any you we all have that
friendly for 20 years if you got snapped
you would that's all you would talk
about you'd be like at the McDonald's
back to you like can I get a quarter
pounder I haven't had one of these in
about it you wanna know why that was a
loose baby I was a loose baby I came
back what if the baby fell onto a
cigarette a little cigarette just came
back to those people that are like what
if I stole a car during The Purge and
then the next day do I have to register
it are we those guys Jessica or are we
just two dreamers
you're dreaming stupid I'm dreaming of
babies that wake up with cigars in their
mouth after five years
lose babies uh
we need to remember the fact that the
planet Earth is not in the same spot it
was five years prior so Theory those
people would just like appear in space
right because the Earth is anyways uh
yeah I need to what about my girl
underwater if she dusted right when she
was finishing her something and she come
back with a mouthful
the MJ 2997 asking is what kind of
forever oscar-worthy as a drama they're
going to do it on Thursday I know I know
but let's remember they've expanded the
Oscars best picture category to 10
Possible movies they can do 10
nominations this happening After the
Dark Knight to get nominated did not get
nominated there was a lot of outcry what
kind of forever famously nominated for
Best Picture won a couple of oscars
black panther or black panther sorry yes
uh won a couple Oscars I believe at
least one for costume design
it's gonna be it's definitely gonna be
nominated you think you think in your
opinion as a movie guard would you like
to see it on the list I would like to
see Angie
here we go
I think some acting now
everyone deserves an acting on every
single every even Leticia Wright is look
I don't care what people may feel right
Leticia Wright puts on a hella fine
performance I mean if Robert Downey Jr
doesn't get it I'll go crazy
just kidding
Suave saying there was no break room
yesterday I demand a refund you'll get
your refund uh of zero dollars
um David Z asking what's a bigger shock
doom and black panther kind of forever
or the Jets beating the bells then they
spell out Jets because I assume most
people from uh most Jets fans can't read
or write uh Bucky Barnes ATL saying for
our great moderators love you guys yes
thank you to our moderators in the chat
as Freight girl loves to remind you like
this stream subscribe to the channel if
you haven't already uh
uh
Dino Cummings asking is the movie okay
for kids eight or nine years old what
are your thoughts on that uh I just
think there's a lot of information and
yeah I would only be worried about that
because I don't think it could translate
to very young young kids unless we
release some sort of simple like
explanation video for people and
children with a man with a mind of a
child on our Channel perhaps that'll
come I guess the last thing I have to
say is I hope the Jets if they make the
playoffs they don't play on January 6th
because they're usually okay okay okay
uh
is so aptly pointed out we want to
remind you guys so make sure to vote
today if you haven't voted it's a voting
day across the country if you're in line
stay in line baby oh and the music is
amazing Vortex pay attention the the
Tallow Canal music especially oh my God
oh my God incredible yeah they use like
sea sound I don't know how to I mean
listen I know it's tough you didn't take
some jokes what do you use the IGN
review I just
yeah listen to the music I'm one of
those people that's so basic usually I
don't notice like I play music and
camera work because I'm just an idiot I
just all I can see that's right in front
of me but the music Beautiful Dominique
Thorne Is Amazing by the way she's
incredible stop I've heard the Rihanna
song is incredible no it makes you cry I
guarantee you'll be strong in the
credits that plays over it just the
rolling critics is really good too it's
in another language I don't understand
no I was asking you guys again today for
confirmation because Tommy you saw last
night did you see it yesterday too or
you saw it you went to the premiere uh
wow action day
um Tommy you said too last night at your
screening there was only one credits
scene in the middle of the credits
nothing at the very end yeah do you
think his his still stands with the ones
and Jay was saying this too I think
there is going to be one at the end yeah
I know I think they're nuts because they
know they can't trust mostly Vanity Fair
um
I think there will be I think there's
going to be one difference do you know
how I'm gonna be the only one one
they're going son of a [ __ ] my nephews
on Friday and I gotta be honest as much
as it seems like I'm just doing good
uncle
works I think there is I think I think
that's what's happening everybody knows
about them guys like I said before rush
through the movie to get to the end
come on do what I say don't want to
don't do what I do okay I'm I'm very
excited I'm still uh filled with rage
that I have not been able to see it yet
but I don't want a Brandon I think we've
got tickets oh sometime around 7 P.M on
Thursday
uh join us here tomorrow at the same
time pending internet uh be sure to like
like And subscribe to the channel uh and
make sure you check out Jess's spoilers
for you black panther all kinds of
forever
Jessica's amazing what's that on the
channel if you're Southern and you sound
like Tommy's impression oh my gosh
Jessica I do not always recommend a
Southern Man
thank you for tuning in today we'll see
you here tomorrow same time uh have a
great rest of your day bye Breakers bye
room is late as gay as we'll see you
trash bags
[Music]